والدك شهد بعض تجلياتك ابدا معركه عنك
كتبت له قصيده اهداء لوالدك لا كتبت اشياء
يعني لها علاقه بوالدي لانه
بقي
رغم انه متى
صغيرا
وانا كنت طفل في وقت ما مات الا ان تاثير
كان قوي جدا في نفس في حياتي
لسببين وان كان هو
مناضل في الحزب الاشتراكي الحزب الوطني
كانت الاتحاد الوطني واعتقل عده مرات وانا
عشت هذه الاعتقالات كطفل
وعشت عودته من هذه الاعتقالات
وفي احدى عودته لم يعمر طويلا بعدها حوالي
سته اشهر وتوفي عزب يعني ولذلك لا لا اظن
تعذب نفسيا
وهو كان كان شخص
تقليدي يعني
لباس تقليدي وكان فقيه ودرس في القرويين
في مدينه فاس ولكن لم يكن محافظا كانت
تقليديا ولكن لم يكن محافظا كان منفتحا
فبهذا المعنى كان كان مؤثر كتير في حياه
في نصك اظن طبعا رغم انه لم اعيش معه
كثيرا